LEIGHA JARETT: Just like a
Ferrari, every part of BigQuery
was designed to make
your queries run fast.
And that includes
BigQuery's managed storage.
In today's episode, we're
going under the hood
to figure out exactly how
BigQuery stores this data so
that you can make informed
decisions on how to optimize
your BigQuery storage.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When talking about
BigQuery storage,
there are a few things I
always like to point out.
First off, BigQuery offers
fully managed storage,
meaning you don't have to worry
about provisioning servers
or worry about
configuring any hardware.
All sizing is done
automatically and you only
pay for what you use.
Next, BigQuery uses what
we call columnar datastore.
Taking a step back for a
moment, traditional relational
databases, like
Postgres and MySQL,
store data row by row in
record-oriented storage.
This makes them really good
at transactional updates,
for example, changing
the status of an order
because they only need
to open up a single row
to read or write data.
However, if you want to perform
an aggregation like summing up
the Sale Price column to
get your total revenue,
you would need to read the
entire table into memory.
BigQuery, on the other
hand, uses columnar storage,
where data is co-located
by column rather than row.
This makes BigQuery an ideal
solution for analytical use
cases.
Now, to calculate
the total revenue,
BigQuery will only need to
read in the Sale Price column.
Internally, BigQuery stores data
in a proprietary column format
called Capacitor.
One really cool
thing about Capacitor
is that it uses relevant
factors like the type of data
and how the data is being used
to reshuffle rows and encode
columns.
One example is
run-length encoding.
Let's pretend that the
value 1 appears three
times in a row in your data.
Rather than storing
1, 1, 1, Capacitor
can instead store 1:3.
But what if the rows
are ordered such
that there are no long
runs of the same value?
Well, to solve this,
Capacitor simply
reorders the rows to
obtain a compact encoding.
So now we know about
BigQuery's file format.
But where do these files
actually get saved?
The persistence
layer for BigQuery
is provided by the distributed
file system throughout Google--
Colossus.
Colossus has a ton of disks
that live on a ton of servers.
But when you have
so many, chances
are that dozens of disks
are going to fail each day.
So the goal is to make
sure that no data is lost.
Colossus ensures durability
by using something
called erasure encoding, which
breaks data into fragments
and saves redundant
pieces across
a set of different disks.
However, to ensure the data
is both durable and available,
the data is also replicated
to another availability zone
within the same region
that was designated
when you created your data set.
This means data is saved in a
bunch of different buildings
that has a different
power system and network.
The chances of multiple
availability zones going
offline at once is very small.
But if you use
multi-region locations,
like the US or the EU,
BigQuery stores another copy
of the data in an
off-region replica.
That way, the data is
recoverable in the event
of a major disaster.
Aside from replication,
Colossus also
protects your data
by ensuring that it
is 100% encrypted at rest.
Plus, if you want to
control encryption yourself,
you can use customer-managed
encryption keys.
And the great thing
about all of this
is that encoding,
encryption and replication
are included in the price
of BigQuery storage.
So no hidden costs.
So far, we've talked
about the format
in which BigQuery stores data.
And we've talked about
the physical file system
where the data is stored.
But how do we
ensure that data is
stored in a way that makes
our queries as performant
as possible?
BigQuery has a storage optimizer
that helps arrange data
into the optimal
shape for querying
by periodically rewriting files.
Files may be written
first in a format that
is fast to write to.
But later, BigQuery
will format them
in a way that's fast to query.
Aside from the optimization
happening behind the scenes,
there are also a few
things that you can
do to further enhance storage.
First off, BigQuery allows
you to partition your table
when it's created.
Partitioning basically allows
you to divide large tables
into smaller chunks
or partitions, which
are stored in a physically
separate location.
When you include a "where"
clause in your query,
BigQuery will only need
to read in the partitions
that you actually need.
BigQuery allows you to
partition data based on the time
it was ingested--
a date column with
granularity as low as hourly,
or an integer column.
When deciding on
partitions, you should
consider how people
at your organization
are using this data.
For example, if data
consumers are most often
looking at orders
placed in the past week,
it might make sense to partition
your table by order date
so that you can
efficiently read data just
from the past seven days.
Partitions are
designed for places
where there is a
large amount of data
and a low number
of distinct values.
A good rule of thumb is
making sure partitions
are greater than 1 gigabyte.
If you over partition
your tables,
you'll create a lot
of metadata, which
means that reading
in lots of partitions
may actually slow
down your query.
If you need higher cardinality
or you have a smaller table,
you should use clustering.
Clustering is like
sorting your tables
on a particular set of columns.
For example, clustering
our table by customer
ID would sort the rows
based on the customer ID.
In BigQuery, you're
able to choose up
to four columns to cluster on.
This allows for
efficient lookouts
because the query engine
needs to open files
that have the cluster key.
For example, if
we query our table
and include a
filter to only look
at orders placed by
customer number one,
then we only need to
open up this file.
The tricky part of clustering
is maintaining the clusters
when the data is changing.
But BigQuery solves
this by periodically
reclustering each table.
This happens automatically
without any user intervention
or additional cost.
Partitioning and clustering
are often used together.
We can partition by the low
cardinality field, for example,
the created_at
date of the order,
and cluster by the
high cardinality one,
like customer_id.
This lets you operate over a
date range slice of the table,
but it also lets
you find records
from a particular customer
without having to scan
all the data in the partition.
As with partitioning,
you should always
try and figure out
the types of questions
users will be asking of the data
to decide the keys that you'll
use to cluster.
Want to learn more about
storage optimization?
Check out the links below.
Thanks for tuning
into this episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight."
And don't forget to
subscribe to our channel
on YouTube for
other great content.
Look out for our next episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight."
And remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]